President Biden is facing backlash from
some Progressive allies for his efforts
to avoid a national rail strike rail
workers are threatening to walk off the
job they're asking for increased pay and
paid time off but President Biden is
asking Congress to intervene to stop
this possible strike in order to protect
the economy during this very busy
holiday shipping season weisha Zhang is
at the White House with more on the
story weisha good morning things are
getting very tense in this situation
good morning Gail good morning to
everyone well you know bipartisanship is
such a rarity these days that when there
is some it's a big deal and Democratic
and Republican leaders agree that a rail
strike would be devastating to the U.S
economy and that's why they are
scrambling to prevent one President
Biden sat down with the top four
Congressional leaders for the first time
since the midterm elections he told them
it was not an easy call but he thinks
they have to Halt collective bargaining
to protect the economy house Speaker
Nancy Pelosi said the house would vote
today to adopt a tentative agreement
that the administration brokered back in
September four unions have voted against
it the contract includes a 24 raise over
five years but workers want paid sick
leave which Progressive support Senator
Bernie Sanders tweeted that he intends
to block the bill saying of the paid
sick leave quote please don't tell me
that the rail industry can't afford it
rail companies spent 25.5 billion
dollars on stock by tax and dividends
this year if real workers walk off the
job it could mean even more financial
pain for the average American already
dealing with high inflation it could
wreak havoc on the supply chain and
delay getting Goods to store shelves
which might lead to prices going up on
just about everything right before
Christmas Senate Majority Leader Chuck
Schumer said that he is working to get
enough votes to pass the legislation
he's not sure if he's there yet if
Congress does not intervene the strike
could start next Friday Tony
all right we should we will be watching
thank you very much